Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, And welcome back to "Inside."
Now, I THINK if I had to guess about "Inside,"
and what "Inside" means,
we're inside the machiiiinne-ahhh..
Hehahaha,
...No, that's probably not it.
We're Inside the SEWERS, which is a very apt description of where we are,
And we're INSIDE the realm where MARKIMOO is not smart enough to keep this guy away from death.
HELLO!
HI SIR!
Are you friendly?
I guarantee not!
I'm going to find a way to push you- ooh
Huh-OOH.
Uhh-DONT MIND ME! Don't mind me.
Wha-Huh- DAAD! UNCLE BEN!
Uncle-Oooh.
WHY?
Woah.
WOAH-WOAH-
WHUHHNOOHOHOH
Oh my goodness gracious
WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY IS THIS WHERE THEY JUST
RUN UP AND KILL THE FIRST CHILD THEY SEE?!
My goodness.
That's just no good.
Like- Unless I have some distinguishing remarks on me, Or-
Marks on me??
Wh-Why is their first instinct "WUAAAHH!
IT'S A KID!
KILL 'EM!
KILL 'EM DEAD!
MURDER 'EM!
CHOKE EM UP AGAINST THE RAILING" for some fuckin' reason.
Who knows?
I don't know...
Does anybody know? I don't know.
Okay , bye bye...
I'm gonna steal your submar-ohhn
I'm gonna steal it cause I'm a rebel and I'm awesome
I'm gonna steal it because I'm a rebel
and I'm awesome
So goodbye!
huhba-
[stupid laughter]
Woah- Ehp- Uhp-
YEAAAAHH!
Hahaha ! Mine now bitches
Ooh! Free ride!
Somehow, as a child, I know how to pilot this
but frankly I'm not surprised....
Can I go further down?
Ooo~ I'm gunna go down.
Ooh I love this
Oh this is so cool!
I love the diversity, like the diversity in this game is phenomenal.
Like the different environments is one thing, traveling through the world that's  one thing entirely...
thing
traveling through the world that's
that's one thing entirely
But THIS is like, it's like a shift. It's like the same concept but in a different light.
Like making a vehicle a part of it; it's just pretty cool.
Igotta be-
HAAAAABOOSHKI!
Oh, I thought I was going to pass through it.
I don't know why I thought I was going to pass through the floor.
I don't know why I thought I was going
to pass through the floor
I'm really trying here it's not working
though that's not twerking though
I'm really trying here It's not working though,
Ah its not TWERKing though,
ok so that's a blank wall over there
Okay, so that's a blank wall over there...
that's it is nothing over there like
something
So that's just nothing over there.
So like something,
oh whatever haha oh yeah that was awful
person
Oh, whoa what am i doing?
Oooh! Yeah! That was awesome!
well awesome it's terrifying down here
oh I don't like this at all
That was awesome!
Oh it's terrifying down here!
Oh I don't like this at all... (same mark same)
all gotta do not like this what is this
where is this city built that they're
Oh God I do not like this...
What is this?
Where is this city built that they're underneath
- What is that?
what is that all that's crack in the
wall but there's a giant chain over
Oh that's a crack in the wall.
But there's a giant chain over there...
Is that a chain? I cant tell what that is but there's something gigantic in the background there.
I can't tell what that is but that's
something gigantic in the background
It's huge!
And I know I need to crack that;
but man what is this place?
Where are they?
There's so many unanswered questions and I love it!
I love like a story that
doesn't tell itself completely right off
the bat it's-it's told
There's a certain
word for it but it's a game that's story
is told in the environment
and that's
what I can really appreciate
Like you glean .. like this whole universe exists
and the thing about game it's a visual
medium so of course you can
you can
like execute these ideas through just
telling about the environment and then
you can infer your own interpretation
about it
HA BOOSHKEY!
ski I gotta charge up better for those
man i hope i get to do that a million
I gotta charge up better for those,
man i hope i get to do that a million times over,
times over because that is the coolest
power I've ever had
cause that is the coolest power I've ever had.
And thankfully nothing can harm me out here
I'm totally safe that weird red ominous
glow in the distance is nothing bad for
me and I'm going to be a ok
even though I'm going farther and
farther down
Which doesn't bode...
Doesn't bode well for meee!!!
I love this, the freaking whip lash this kid gets.
Oh but that's so cool the animations inside of the thing,
That's so cool,
Oh there we go; do I
got a boost through that
I'll do it I probably don't
Nah I don't...
Ooh what is that?
Why?
Is that a projector screen?
That's weird, why is it in there?
Did this used to be a classroom or something?
Oh Oooh
Oh God!
It's building inside me!!!
Oh! Run away! Run away!
Blaaahh!
Oh It's reinforced. I have to do it again.
Oh God!
Oh no!
It's happening again!
Oooh save yourself!
Boink!
Hello!
Oh It's so cool.
I'm gonna get it
Hang on,  hang on, hang on, hang on!
One more, one more, one more!
Eh- Puueh!
Did that do it? Did I just give myself a concussion here,
or is that just not gonna work
'cause it's reinforced concrete?
Probably!
We've breached!
Okay, so there's something over here.
Maybe I can launch myself out of the water;
that be totally awesome and I love that
But at the same time,
I bet that's not the case but maybe it
is the case
Okay, I'm gonna do that... eh eh eh.
Ohhh, I see what it's doing. Oh, its a crack leading upwards so I did need to keep
what I was doing
EH! Heheheheheh!
More?! More!?
more MORE yeah
Uhn-neh-neh-neh-PAH!
Okay so there's more to this.
It's cracks forming.
Whoops, I meant to go more horizontal then that...
Man this poor kid!
Just getting the shit beat out of him
This is probably definitely not what this thing was built for;
but just continually gets abused like
this by the small child
Ooh! what?
I didn't know about that!
Oh! I didnt know I could hop out of the thing
Oh so I opened up probably a hole big enough for me to get through.
Don't drown, don't drown.
hang on .. don't drown
so if I cant get through there then I must be able to
yeah!
I just swim through!
Well who would have thunk it would have been
that easy
Not me... not me I tells ya
So does that mean I could open it up for, hopefully, my ship to come bursting through?
Nope! We gotta do this the old fashion way!
Without a fun ship
that saves us from death but
I don't know if it would been in the
universe to have a giant monster come attack(?) me but that would have been COOL!
and all!
I just for some reason didn't think of the possibility of letting go
the one cool thing that I had in this
world not saying this world-
Not saying this world isn't cool-
I'm saying this poor kid only had one thing to his name and it was that ship and it was
so cool
Alright, so, what are we doing here.
So this seems to be an old decrepit school;
which would explain the projector that
we had the other room over there
But it
would not explain -- Why this world is so fucked uuuuuuup.
Well it would kind of explain why this world is so fucked up because there's
just a lot of bullshit that's going on-
This is going to kill me....
Ahh!
It was going to kill me in a different way!!!
Oh God!
Oh god, oh, god, oh god, oh god!
god oh god oh
Oh .. Ow...
Ouch cabibbles...
I stopped for some reason cause I thought I could open the hatch
and that
would have been a stupid avenue and I don't know why I even tried
There's a lot of my life
I don't even know why I try
Alright! Boopity Boop Boop Boop!
Run! Scoobidoop!
Oh don't you come near me you biiittcchhh!
Ha - Bleuf!
Errrg, Hergbergaflerbal!
furball
Ok... what about that,
so that was good...
That was nice
Oh good! I got a tube to keep floating
and what good does that do me except nothing.
Okay so I can go back and I can go through the door without the risk of
dying a horrible death.
Bye ratties!
I scared you once why'd you come back?
I'll maybe come back again, so you best never return to this place ever...
ever again! You damn dirty rats!
Okay. Anyways, carrying on...
So there's gotta be something over...
Why does it look like the projector screen from the other room over there?
Like why is that there?
Oh who knows --  why is any of this here.
Why is this a school -- here?
It reminds me of Midgar from Final Fantasy VII , a city built on top of a city.
Is that a land mine? 0.o
Something tells me that might be an explodey device!
Whoo!
Eugh!?
What'd I do? What'd I do? What'd I do?
Oooh!
That is not what I expected to happen.
I expected that to blast me into the next universe!
Weeeee!
It blasted me up a bit which is awfully nice of it!
Okay! Thank You!
You're a delightful device; I don't know what your purpose is,
but you're really cool.
Alright so what do we got over here?
Oooooh....
Interesting...
You know its interesting
that the developers ran with the same
fundamental concept of a game
Considering that the last game was a child wandering through a unknown universe
full of perils
and this is a child
wandering through an unknown universe
full of perils.
Both
Like
technically speaking
similar ideas... if not like identical
ideas on paper but like
the execution is still
fascinatingly interesting
Cause I mean like i--
it's one of those things where it's it's
not really something that that can only
be done once
you know there's- if
like McDonald's, Wendy's, Burger King,  can
all sell--
Ooh! My boat!
Oh boy bubble butt is back!
if like they can all sell the same burger, and this is
reaching quite a bit for my idea here,
but if they can all sell the same burger I
don't understand whty the same
fundamental concept can be redone.
The only reason that I mentioning this is
that it's fascinating that the
developers did it
the the exact same theme again which are
AHHH
What the fuck was that!?
I'll stop talking about the game as if I  know anything
because I do not!
Alright! Now I go hippity - hop over.
Heh.... Booskey!
Oh boy...
I do not pretend like I know what I doing. Woah!
Somethin ' bad is down here.
I thought they weren't going to have anything for me
Oh? You think that's going to stop...
Meee!
That' s what I thought
Alright.
You sons of bitches down here - what are you doing?
Is this going to open for me? Oh it does
But is there something down here for me? Hang
on
peekaboo for just a second.
Oh man.
I'm just tempted to explore all the environments,
but I don't know
Ah! Look at you! I found something! Okay
Alright, I'm using my big brain.
What do we got over here?
What do we got? Is this where the monsters lurk so deep down in the
darkness? Probably.
Heh - Bleugh
Heh - - Bleugh
Okay so what is this? Where is this?
Where am I?
Oh, fascinating...
But I don't know if I can reach that...
Heh!
Bail, bail, bail, bail, bail! Ahh, damnit!
Okay so... I cant reach that yet...
Can i?
I can't , right?
No yeah you cant,
Oh! There's a ladder over there. Okay
that's what I was looking for.
Okay.
I wouldn't have thought that they would have put something very secret like that was a secret
that probably wasn't gunna be easily found,
but I found it, none the less-- Jump in!!
You do the thing!
Whoops, sorry, you almost had it...
C'mon can you stop goofing around? I know
this is the first little bit of freedom
that you've had as a horrible zombie
like person,
but tell me...
ok so there's got to be a way to do this
that I can get him in there
So if he's...
Ah.
If he's on top of it
No, no. No, no. No, no.
*Mark thinking for a very very long time*
(i'm uncomfortable by this silence)
Eh.
Okay so if he's on top of it, and then I get in it,
And then he gets booshed up
into that thing, then he should just...
Yeah... YEAH...
Heh, You're gonna be fine, don't worry about it! Habooskey! AHHH!
Yeheheheah
Yeah man!
Yeah man!  Okay,
so we get out of there...
I'm gonna leave that there in case I need him to go
over there,
but I do not think I do...
So if he's over there
That means we got control of the second doo-daddy,
we should be good.
Walkity Walk! Hippity Hop over to the candy shop!  Boppity boop bop bop boop!
BOINK!
Ah! Ha - boink!
Ah... Ha - boink? Okay.
Oh did that guy die? Oh no....
He's just gonna be hangin' there for all eternity?
Well that's mean
well that's mean.
So what'd that do?
Awh is this not actually a secret and
this is actually something that I needed
to find.
Is that what this was?
Awh, come on man... okay...
So that probably unpowered something that's gonna be in the other area
and then that's where we needed to go
and then everything is gonna be fine
and I'm not that smart
I'm just a little ahead of the curve
But okay....
Heh - Bleugh
Alright so if that was that, that means that would unlock something... Over here!
Wait where's that wire going? I see the cable.
I see the cable, where does that go?
Oh it kind of ended, where'd it go? Where'd you go? Where'd you go you cable bastard?!
Something over here maybe?
Ooh what is that? Ah that's nothing...
I don't think actually anything.
Yeah I don't think that's actually to anything .
I mean it couldn't have been to nothing. That's the number one thing
to understand from this.
It could-- It literally couldn't have been to nothing.
Maybe it was something over there
and I just didn't get to it yet! Oh wait there's more.
Hang on what's up here? No? Damnit...
Alright, I guess that's not it...
(Sighs)
I feel like I... Maybe you guys are very angry at me because I found a
secret and then immediately
walked away from a secret which would be a rrreally
shitty thing for me to do.
Then again, maybe this wasn't powered...
Then maybe it was
was totally fine. I don't know
Alright, so I'm gonna hop out of here and try to get to that button.
It's pretty far down but I think it should be okay.
Heh - Beugh ... Heh - Beugh
Okie Dokie then! Alrighty!
Get some air! Don't drown.
Number one priority here.
I gotta pile you somewhere where you're not gonna get stuck
Okay that's not very deep, but did that help us?
Damn it, I don't see what that - ugh - I don't see what the deactivation signal did...
It didn't actually do anything.
Can I launch around here somewhere?
I could get out and get through here... Maybe...
Yeah I can get out and go through here. But is there some reason for me to be over here yet?
I don't know
I don't even know if there are secrets in this game.
*Gasp*
I just realized how vulnerable I am!
I saw that monster thing and now I'm in that area that that it is...
Oh shit...
I should've gotten more air! Oooo I should've gotten more air! Oh no! I'm dead...
Well...
That
Went
Well
For Me!
But I mean if the water level is up
Then I can over it why did I lower the water
level I didn't actually need to do that
Did I not actually need to do that?
I'm very confused...
I don't think I needed to do that
It was just a shiny red button in front of my face how could I ignore it?
it was a shiny red button right in front
of my face how can I ignore it
So if the water level is higher
then I can actually launch myself over,
I can just swim over the obstacle.
Yeah this isn't a problem at all
Huh...
But the thing isn't open...
So I gotta swim back.
Oooh It all makes sense now!
Okay I just needed to do that first
and then, push the button by myself.
Far away from my device
that protects me from the denizens of the deep
So that's good.
Well that's not good cause I'm gonna be all alone and terrified.
But it's good as in it's gonna help me progress.
Alright'
Hoobie - Doof!
Alrighty th - up heh heup don't drown! Come on don't drown!
Stop coughing underwater,
you've been holding your breath for like ten seconds
you've been holding your breath for like
10 seconds you'd think that you could do
a little more than that
Alright...
But it's fine, I'm not complaining about the survival skills
of this likely like twelve year old kid..
all right let us away with his dinner
though something is just a reflection of
Alright
Let us awaaay!
What is this down here?
Awh, I thought that was something...
It was just a reflection in the water
Heh
Heh - Beeeuuuggghh There we go
that's the stuff now we're on track
Okay so if we're on track here...
We can boosh through here!
Real good! (Alien Sound)
Ah...
Oh - Wai - Woah! What are you?!
What is that?!
What are you?!
What are you?
What ARE you?!
Hey!!
Hey!
Why can you breath underwater?
And why is your hair so gosh darn long?
I'm 'onna get yeh
I'm gonna get yeh
Ha Booskey!
Woaaah! You a fast one...'
Ha - Booskey!
I'm gonna name you...
Sally
Or Emma
I'm gonna name you every single random name that pops into my head as we're going through this story.
Sooo...
Samanth...era..
How you doing Samanthera?
Wait who did i name Samanthera I can't remember...
Hey, heyeyeyeyey
Ahh!
NO!
Don't do that!
Why'd you do that?
How'd you - Oh God! Oh God!
I am dead...
Well...
That's not good.
Maybe I need to shake her off once that happens...
Okay...
Probably
Hey, hey, hey!
Eeeeugh! Nope that aint it!
Well tha - hahaha
Heh, I don't know how she's able to do that.
I don't think I wanna see what's going on in there
Probably horrible
Maybe I just gotta keep a light on her?
That must be it.... Yeah
It's like Peek - A - Boo
Hey! Hey, hey...
Yeah you better back off...
You better back - Hey! Hey!
Eugh - ugh I'm getting angry!
Ha - Booskey!
Ok so she's over - Peekaboo!
Yeah that's what I thought.
Eugh! Samanthera you gotta go away!
Sorry
Whoo!
Shined!! I Shined it on!!
WHY THE FUCK!
Did it not shine on!?
Awh that's stupid, I shined it right on.
It just I hit the ground and got stunned, that's what it was. It was my own damn fault.
Didn't mean to do that!
I got you in my sights
I got your number now
Not that I wanted it in the first place Samanthera.
Hey!
How bout you don't huh?
How bout you just don't.
Schwoopty
eh.
Eeeeh Okay so we're making progress
We're doing good. Weh
Weh - Wehh Wuhhh
There we go. Good thing it auto tracks
Because that, that's definitely beneficial
So where I.. Oh I know where to go.
Oh wai - Wah wah wah wahhh
What're you doin'?
NOO!
I see yah
Oh I know what I need to do...
I need to - No God damn it! Not then!
That's not what I wanted to do!
I wanted to go down, It auto-tracked to it.
Yeah I was pushing straight down.
I - It does that thing where it guides you along where it wants you to go.
I need to get her on one side and then
close the door on her
and that's what I need to do.
Okay I got it , I got it.
Eh, eh. Hey, hey
Heh - Bubb
Heh - Bubba ... No...
Okay so I just need to keep her right there.
And slam it shut on her right there!
Bam! She's done. Okay got that.
Easy peasy lemon squeeze me
Okay so now that is taken care of.
I
Can figure out the fuck where I am
Where the fuck am I? Oh I know what I need to do!
What would happen If i were to just bash through this?
While she was here. I thought about - oops
Ohhh, cause you need multiple bashes and it breaks your light.
Ah I see
Heh  - Neh, Neh - Beeeuugh
Okie Dokie that's why it was...
okay...
That makes more sense, so how many more of those things are they
and why is that thing even a thing that exists?
Oh, I think I'm done
Am I done with this for good?
I think I might be done with this. Okay.
I'll hop out and we are on the beach.
So! Anyways that is all for this episode here.
We're getting into some real interesting stuff and I really like this game already
I like it alot...
So thank you everyone so much for watching!
And as always I will see you
in the next video
Bye - Bye!